or pour la première fois des
responsables de la sécurité
si on juge et pas n'importe où akin
choix il ya les symboles à tous points
de vue c'est de là qu'est partie la
révolution c'est là aussi qu'on m'avait
annoncé un génocide un charnier où les
images avaient fait le tour du monde
l'information dé nos clients il
n'empêche c'est la conclusion des
manifestations sanglantes qui ont fait
des victimes
raquin officiel les attentes et traduit
en justice la fin africa com
les morts de timisoara en tout cas pas
les 21 inculpés aussi c'est de l'auvent
de la securitate la toute-puissante
accusé deux fois le général émile matri
chèque de contact hommage dernier
survivant du trio de généraux chargés
directement quand une fille ce coup de
réprimer dans le sang la révolte de tous
les joueurs sous le nom cette ville est
devenue le symbole du soulèvement
il a été ensuite empêchés de
l'accusation de manipulation le fameux
charnier découvert
on n'était pas loin les 4000 morts
annoncés tout changer du à 94
déclarations du procureur ousmane
aujourd'hui à l'ouverture du procès
retransmis à la télévision roumaine
mais le feuilleton macabre continue le
général macri devra répondre ainsi que
le polonais de la police à poya de la
disparition de quarante cadavres de la
morgue de l'hôpital de timisoara qui
aurait été transporté secrètement dans
un camion piégé au crématorium de
decarel soir devant les militaires mais
militaire le rôle de l'armée selon des
sources bien informées devrait être
évoquée dans les prochains jours
accusé d'avoir fait tirer sur la foule